hey everybody I am Alexa Ray Korea and
this is my lovely colleague Jeremy Jane
and we're playing Final Fantasy 15
episode DUS I'm so excited this is out
today if you purchased Final Fantasy
type zero there should be a code for
this in your copy wait you mean you
meant to say if you purchase this demo
you also get type zero yeah if you
purchase this demo you also get Final
Fantasy type zero which is also a pretty
cool game we're just going to start
we're just gonna go just gonna go for it
do it um so we got a chance I got a
chance to play this game I did not get a
chance to play this game oh my God stop
rubbing it in my face it's so good I'm
so this is going to be a all of you
viewing out here who have never seen
this game I'm right alongside you this
is going to be an adventure for us this
is uh I got to see it during this takes
a little while load uh this this uh this
demo is like I think it's like 5.27
gigabytes it's a pretty big thing um but
uh it is uh I hear if you want to do
everything without wandering around it's
about three hours long so it's pretty if
you if you I was told if you do
everything right uh if you wander around
then it's a little bit more um it's
pretty hefty I got to play it at paist
uh earlier this month and uh got to do
some combat running around like this
will open up I'll show you the tutorial
we'll fight and then we'll go um
exploring go dick around in uh in uh the
world of deske the world of
yeah so we are just for backstory since
you can't read the text that's
underneath us um noctis and his friends
ignis prompto and gladiolus are on the
road in their car on their way
somewhere and uh the car breaks down so
they need to get money to repair the car
and just hang out together uh as you can
see they're they're camping they've uh
they're cooking something back there
okay here we go hell yeah uh so are they
on the I
I want to talk over the cut scene I'm
sorry I'll ask my questions later this
is so good their hair all looks perfect
even though they just slept in a tent
perfect perfect
hair they got cell phones
here yeah cell phones and Final Fantasy
is an
iPhone think it's Samsung Galaxy oh my
God I mean his hair looks like it's seen
better days really cuz it my hair
doesn't look like that when I wake
up that man's abs holy th those do not
look real those are AB implants oh
man that
hurt look at those eyebrows actually we'
booted this up earlier on xbone and the
eyebrows looked weirdly bad like the
game looks almost the same on xbone but
the eyebrows or the just like the hair
textures were really weirding me
out yeah see he's not he's like oh my
hair is perfect he's super Caucasian
looking yeah that's a white hate to be
that this kid right here oh come on
don't be that way you know I didn't mean
to do it he's got such anime like sabot
movement at his arms holy crap I like
that he's got like he's got like
freckles and like he does okay something
I've noticed about this demo is like
prompto especially has a very like
typically Final Fantasy well like the
games will have like the almond shaped
eyes they'll look a little whatever but
this guy is so different looking yeah
straight Whitey Whitey don't say that
I'm white you did it just call me Titan
why is it vibrating so violently my
controller is vibrating right now's
going on in the
world morning there buddy
a see look they've got so much hair gel
in that that survived the night look at
the way they look at him Little Prince
octus not technically uh I know it's I
feel like there going to be a weird
dynamic where they sort of baby him cuz
he's the prince but they're all kind of
rough on him cuz they're like his
friends those gloves to did he sleep in
Su did he sleep in those gloves and suit
what what oh god I I remember this part
enormousness of visit they all they all
tap him they all like like give him a
little love tap a look at that look at
that bandana on his
arm
wow couldn't ask for better weather give
him the glove slap do it give him the
glove
slap oh he challenged him to a duel he
slapped him with the glove that's
automatically a
duel oh man look at his hair it never
moves wow it's frozen like
that that is a stunning view wow you
know what would be more stunning what if
we knew we weren't bounded into just the
region of duske yeah I mean it's pretty
big yeah it's true it is pretty big I'm
not trying to undercut dusk here I am
excited the amount you can hit the
invisible walls though like Behemoth big
hunting down its horns could get us the
money if it doesn't get us killed
wouldn't worry his dead without he's
like a cartoon character yeah he is a
cartoon character they're all like
pretty realistic when they talk except
for him that's good enough for me and
they're all wearing like some variation
of like a leather coat or duster he's
like a like a caricature of like a 1950s
American boy he's like that's good
enough for me G
goly he's just got the strangest like
outlier of a personality he's so cute
all right here we go all right tutorial
so we
need4 we need 24,000 Gill to repair our
car ala as the resident Final Fantasy
expert I need you to tell me 24,000 Gil
what is that in US American dollars in
the year
2015 about $24,000
um I'm just kidding you don't have to
answer that uh I don't know because Gil
are pretty easy to get okay so probably
like a few bucks check this [__] out out
what's that that's a cloud oh oh no
there's like a weird Cloud it's like a
weird thing looks like a campfire is
exploding in the distance oh my god look
what are those uh I don't know look at
those things want to go to them let's
let's let's walk away from the tutorial
oh it's making you walk super slow oh my
God all right let's power through the
tutorial and then we'll go see what
those and then we'll go explore giant
dinosaurs if you noce watch him
he'll the what we black leather all the
time no like look black leather is in
this
game they had to take the entire dudes
look at these dudes it's a bad crew it's
a bad looking
crew can I run now yeah no just they can
they're they're like metrosexual Sons of
Anarchy
go all right all right oh there you go
okay now you can KN come here oh my God
you just plowed through I'm here bro oh
how convenient one single
flyer oh wow red Behemoth what are the
chances only 1,000 more guil than we
need at this time we could buy like a
potion or something you could buy a m
doll God look at those freaking ABS I
can't stop looking at those abs yeah
dude teach me how to fight they have a
gravitational force oh my God so here's
combat here's our first look at combat
okay so the combat is hot in this game
look at that and this is somebody who's
a fan of the old final this combat is
hot super hot attacking and
defending thanks for thanks for reading
there are two modes to combat all right
okay attack and defense da da da all
right show us what you got You' played
this before so why don't you show
gladiolus the hell is up oh oh
yeah can't get me he's got a really big
sword I
know oh he got me all right that's why
you don't taunt a man with asss like
that oh my God okay hold on the sun was
in my eyes man my hair was in my eyes
there too much of it he looks really
unwieldy with that sword like maybe he
should get a smaller one
aha so noctis has a little bit of the
magic to him oh damn it he's got the
magic in him [__] don't be hitting your
prince I don't think you want to call a
man of that size a batch a
bch oh he must be so pissed he's like I
just can't hit
you so not just's magical power is he
conjures weapons out of the air
yeah it's actually pretty cool I was
wondering when I saw early footage of
this game why he had like a thousand
different on
gladio boom boom boom so you can either
like you can hold down square and he'll
keep going okay so you don't need to
mash like it's like Diablo or something
actually Diablo you can hold
too oh took a hit you got shown what was
up he going to cut to a cut scene where
he shames you for getting
hit so noctus can also warp which is
actually pretty cool it's a really great
way to get across the battle field very
quickly oh and you can use it to like go
heal somewhere too right like you can
warp up there and chill out he throws
that sword so straight just gravity
doesn't even affect it you can also air
strike which I really like Co let's say
you Target and then you boop oh that was
dope
Boop this is really cool I'm in yeah no
this is really cool I'm getting hype the
hype train is just pulled into Jeremy
station I'm going to jump away for a
minute jump is this an mm just jumping
around the
world oh man I was right in the middle
of an air strike yeah that was a sweet
little pause so he has a bunch of
different techniques that are sort of
ascribed to a bunch of his blades so
let's see some drain blade so let's do a
drain blade oh you got drain son let's
do a
tempest he just pulls out the Tempest by
Shakespeare and starts reading
passages he's like stoping I'm jumping
around because I really like the jump
animation very sorry guys you jump real
high so when noctis exhausts his MP
he'll be in stasis and he can go
somewhere else on the battlefield to
recover okay so you can crawl behind a
rock and sort of like get your bearings
a little bit like this watch he even
looks tired look how tired he is he
looks so tired now I have a question for
you Alexa see see the bottom bottom
right oh yeah it's recovering super fast
the MP takes a while though
um so I know you can only play as noctis
in this demo are they have they
announced whether or not you're going to
play as the other characters in the
actual full release or we don't know yet
uh they haven't announced that yet we
have no idea okay
cool I wonder though cuz like I think it
would be cool to control everyone but I
think it's sort of immersive to stick
you only in noctis's position like it
makes you sort of relate to that
character more but the only problem is I
would probably just try to like Jack up
his gear and let everyone else kind of
just fall by the wayside a little bit
you know like get him that nice new
sword and let everyone else deal with
like rubber
helmet is he still teaching you are you
still learning things I am okay Parry
this fool so we can go explore the world
of
duske oh my God you do not want to be on
the receiving end of that dude he is
Nimble with that giant piece of Steel oh
nice that's a Parry oh nice you just did
2K damage on this fool come here mother
just call him mother did you censor
yourself no I admitted I did you
admitted the second half of that phrase
I did okay cuz we're on a stream for the
children you could just call him mother
though just for now like he's like a
mother figure cuz he takes care of you
in the in the deesis of this
game all right do a Dron jump do what
you got to do to get out of this torial
I'm going to heal again tting around
he's like where did you
go what an idiot what a dummy what a dof
look at him he's like flopping around
out there with that GL has had a few
morning vodkas he is looking unsteady
yeah I mean to maintain abs like that
you got to be a little drunk at all
times oh I but I was all right all right
show this fo what's up come here bud end
it now boom par there we
go that's pretty cool oh they're
complimenting me thanks Bros thanks Bros
even though you're slashing him with a
weapon he's like nice job nice job
cutting my legs off
wow thrust you zero okay he has no
Health come get me bro what's happening
why does he have no Health cuz we're in
the tutorial I know but shouldn't you be
injuring him in some
capacity
weapons yeah weapons okay so the
different sword types have different
advantages right yeah I cannot read that
fast but I will take your word for it so
weapons we're going to set our ravage
which is like Melee bar we're going to
give it we're going to ascribe this
weapon which uh negates enemy defenses
which is pretty cool cool I also have to
say I love that UI for equipping weapons
it is so clean and nice looking even if
that's like placeholder UI it looks so
good oh yeah sound like you just said
duske duske they just yell the place of
the name or the name of the place where
they're at duske
home all right let's do
it you are now ready to face gladio an
open com oh my God he came out of the
gates there Jesus
God his Dodge is so casual like he's not
even trying it's real smart me real just
smart me that was a draon job that was
gotcha Jesus I don't even know what
happened
there I wonder uh so people watching the
stream I don't know how many of you have
seen this video but there's a video out
there of uh the summon Rama coming down
ramu I don't know pronunciation I just
look at the words I don't know how to
read them uh but it's it's incredible
and like as opposed to Old final
fantasies where it's like a cut scene it
comes down into the world and there's
like this giant 30 story man who grabs
noctis off the battlefield and it is so
amazing and I don't know if you can
unlock that in this demo or not but we
should definitely try oh we got to get
that it's so cool looking wait a minute
I parried well not according to gladio
you did not want some look at this
though he's got a Batman voice look at
how tired he is like I really like the
little touches to how they move and how
they behave me too but this is so
ridiculously he's just hiding in the
shadow of a rock from a man with a giant
sword look at how ominously he's walking
towards
you kill him end him end his life come
here bud you're my best friend now let
me kill
you look he's just giving up now rescue
him you owe me one thanks I owe you one
that's what I just said you don't need
to repeat me gladio are we done you rude
jerk how many EXs you got oh not that
many track the Behemoth track that
Behemoth I'm like so enraptured by this
thing en Rapture by this thing by the
the game game okay cool no I'm so
excited I thought you meant by the the
Behemoth I'm wait till you see the
Behemoth oh it is a thing I saw footage
a behemoth undertaking is is that uh is
that footage up on gamespot.com tracking
the Behemoth it is maybe I'm not sure I
didn't upload it personally but if not I
will make it happen just a reminder it's
25,000 Gil
kids in case you forgot now why don't we
go for a walk yeah go check out this
giant look it he pushes the bushes out
of his way that's actually nice pushing
some bushing all right go I want know
what these big things yeah go towards
that dinosaur butt oh it's so big dude I
wonder if you can combo it like you can
that behemoth creatur known as a saber a
nasty looking so like hyena Wolves yeah
but with like hyd ultral list Starcraft
Jaws why don't we take some down because
so in in Final Fantasy 15 you gain
experience points and Status Buffs by
camping and cooking right so you need to
harvest oh my God are you going to kill
and eat these animals yeah I'm going to
go kill and eat some animals why not
let's do it Jesus that's brutal this is
real real real things going down in
Final Fantasy 15 you can murder and eat
an
animal oh man and if you notice like
your companions are also doing
significant damage as well yeah I'm glad
they're not just useless while you do
all the
work forget now are you is it auto
Target selecting or are you sort of just
like like how does the Target selection
work cuz you're clearly locked on to one
guy at a time so you can um like it'll
Auto Target for you like there's enemies
nearby he killed him and you can
literally like like do that to jump
between enemies Okay cool so you can
choose which one you're locking on to
basically yeah okay that's good what are
these things ooh more stuff to Mur
what's over here this little
Shack it's a little this is like I'm
getting so much Fallout vibes from this
oh it's the Behemoth I love just
exploring this is what I've wanted Final
Fantasy to be since I was a a we lad a
we lad look at these things so these
drops drop sirloin and
I
gulas get get a gara
steak these things are so defenseless
you are just murdering that oh it'sing
down this is just sad he's like stop
guys please stop
it that's that's like his his mother
she's like leave my child they're just
like killing all these
animals look they're just gang beating
it on the ground beasts they're Gang
Beast in it Gang Beasts oh man AA
sirloin this is hitting me right in the
right in the fields but we got sirloins
now cruelty boost extra exp for
merciless murder I'm just going to do it
again cuz it upsets you wait what's over
here don't don't do things to upset me
not on stream Alexa oh my God only in
real
life only in real life what's this sign
I'm sorry I don't read nonsense oh it
sayland this place right here we are
it's the Lea
tarpits find the Magicite in Aster SLA
I'm going to go check in at my Camp
first and then I'll come back to this
but because you love it so much oh oh
good yeah get her you Tusk Beast use
those tusks for something good yeah yeah
take it notis that's what you
deserve oh you got straight crushed
straight crushed by that angry
dinosaur you better go hide behind a
rock
or just use a potion so everyone that's
what happens when you die you get
knocked down and cry knock just got
knocked knock book
out oh yeah go straight for the babies
Alexa that's good that's a strategy
right there woo knock it over what's
that orangey one over there you think it
has special Sirin maybe my God this is
brutal this uh I really like how quick
the combat is too I like I was replaying
Final Fantasy 9 recently and uh the
combat is so slow in that game yeah no
[__] slow in that game it is so slow I I
love that game so far but I don't know
if I'll ever beat it because it is so
slow oh this one looks real mad oh he
killed all of us we're all dead glad is
help wait no you got zero Health but
you're you're on the on the men you got
15 potions how are you going to fight a
behemoth if you can't even fight these
woolly mammoth tusky guys I'm trying to
save you bro oh thanks look at that
they're healing they healed each other I
didn't have to do [__] and now I'm
leaving friendship prevails bye you are
the worst friend Alexa look at them all
they're actually going this is awesome
it's a a living breathing world use a
cliche because they're actually all
going after you yeah no this is this is
great oh just knock him on his belly and
stab him a bunch yeah
yeah I think ignis needs help yeah ignis
is dead somewhere there he is gotcha Bud
let's put on some more Diamond studded
gloves you'll be
fine all right they're all coming after
us now I just wanted a couple Stakes get
the hell out of here cuz sirloin town is
full of danger I just wanted a couple
Stakes but they but they came after us
that's C look at that now they're all
mad as [__] at that they're all like
Shake it off Shake it off Shake it off
no don't you dare Taylor Swift on me I
will walk off this stream a I will storm
out of this room what's over here I
don't know swamp o oh it's a Behemoth
track Behemoth tracks those are so large
so what do you say you want to explore
more or do you want to go after the
Behemoth uh I want to go after the
Behemoth eventually but let's do a
little exploration before we undertake
that cuz that's sort of the like
Capstone of this demo right oh yeah Okay
cool so let's let's do a little
exploration yeah let's C let's make some
well do we have any food did we get any
Meats from those we did we did get some
food all right let's make a little uh
what's the nearest campground you have
to go to a campground okay just south of
you
just straight towards those animals you
pissed
off oh hey guys just hanging out in the
marsh like we always do on Sundays
hanging out in the marsh oh wow so the
markers like there's no directional you
actually have to look around you to find
hell are they wait a minute what you got
magitech troops yeah they're literally
called magitech troops I just pulled
that out of my ass magitech troops that
was awesome all right uh like a psychic
do we want to go after them or ignore
them murder those gu are you joking
they're coming after after you you're
just going to let them they're robots
right they're not real people I think
they're real people no it said magitech
troops they're like
robotis they're like Terminators aha are
they let's see they have glowy eyes that
doesn't mean they're necessarily robots
I don't know they look kind of like
robot
demons this is like some Oni musher [__]
I know oh you knocked his little hel me
off yeah those are definitely robots
they have metal
hands I'm going to get I'm going to get
black guy is the flag carrier he's like
guys uh guys I'm representing pretty
hard over here but uh somebody flag just
like I will hold this flag until day I
die flag boom need help friends I'm here
until my last breath I'll hold this flag
knock this new oh he's sad how did he
fall down he has full health see look uh
oh if you act too much do you go into
stasis is that what happens I wasn't
paying attention enough during this
tutorial yeah if you're like if you like
run out of MP M magic points what's up
bro did he just smell his hand yeah he
did did you smell your hand bro yeah
he's smelling his gloves he's like did I
get magitech blood on my diamond gloves
you oh there's still one more I was like
what's happening off guard yeah what was
that guy doing why is he green I don't
know he's probably short circus short
circuiting in the swamp short circus
short circus which is a a little known
prequel to short cir TI prompto is you
tired just take a little nap in this
highness is fine yo yeah
yanas I want to go up here and Camp yeah
go camp on that
hungry give me some uh some Sabertooth
stew or whatever after murdering all of
those things yeah let's go eat the
fruits of our
murder eat the fruits of our murder oh
he got
tired who he got tired tired oh you
tired oh you tired his tie glis is like
chilling in the swamp he's like I'm done
with this man you're with these kids he
does look like he's about 48 they're all
like 12 so every day you get a status
boost yay and you
Camp okay on these ancient Nordic runes
you rest to tally experience points and
to level up and it looks like uh ignis
is going to make us a
delicious which is to say anything we
have in a pot with water pretty much all
right let's see what gladiolus is
capable of as a culinary genius oh my
god listen to the
music I can barely hear
it oh it's like some QVC music that
looks good so now we're fresh and immune
ooh immune to potluck stew at least
fresh and immune fresh and immune oh
this is super cute a look at the stars
they're just chilling is there going to
be like I hope there's like little not
like mini games but side activities you
can do at the camp other than E I mean
you can oh can you wow look at that what
the hell you just got like 20 levels I
like I love this UI so like everything
is very clean and very simple and I like
how like the the backgrounds are really
just like muted Grays oh there you go so
we will not get any status ailments and
fresh slightly increases your attack
defense fresh and immune imune what if I
want to camp again
though uh why would you do that kind of
lazy I don't know let Camp again let's
Camp again he's like guys you just want
because there's different food in a
basket there's different foods not so
spoiled he's like you guys want to just
drink wine and sit on this Rock today
it's like dude we're trying to like save
the the world here just want to like Day
drink cuz want to do shots it's like 600
in the morning now I've got this okay I
really hope look at that that's actually
pretty cute looking eggs in a basket
fresh and sharp I'm feeling sharp after
that EAB be Ian a be yeah oh look and
they're in a different like they're
sitting around talking no what do you
think they're talking about how they
just went to bed talk they literally
just wasted a day on their grand
adventure maybe they just want to hang
just level up for eating egg in a basket
yeah prompto ate an egg and gained a
level prompto must be very unexperienced
with the world if eating an egg can
increase his level seriously he's like
you know what I really accomplished
something
today I'm
uh let's do it again no what okay no egg
and a basket if you make me eat another
enab bee I will freak the F out so
here's the thing here's the thing if you
don't hunt like if you don't do Random
Encounters and you don't hunt you don't
gain you don't have any food uh you'll
eat toast oh it'll come up as toast
where the toast come from uh I guess you
have a never ending supply of bread
all right maybe that's one of nas'
magical abilities like he can warp
strike and conjure bread like a
mage I'm a bread Mage yeah why can I be
a bread Mage Like A White Mage a Red
Mage a bread Mage this thing is like
trying to run away from me why are you
murdering more woolly mammoths all right
I super appreciate that the screen like
pauses and lets you like pick your
potions pick your poison because type
zero doesn't I just finished playing
type zero it's pretty good but when you
go to pick items um the game doesn't
pause so you better make sure you're in
a safe spot where an enemy won't get you
if you need to heal up that's kind of
silly I I think making the combat live
action is smart because it makes
everything feel more like exciting and
more present and like you have to pay
attention more but I think making you
like navigate menus in real time is
dumb well what happens I don't know you
made that baby purple and now it's dead
I made it purple and then it died purple
and then without context that is a
disturbing statement you made that baby
purple and then it
died Child Services is coming I don't
know go to it looks like a uh a Hightech
drawing of a
Lotus so this is the Behemoth Trail we
want to go explore right so yeah I mean
let's explore a little bit we can I mean
how long does the Behemoth Mission take
20 minutes or so okay why don't we go
let's go for a run why don't we head
let's go for a little jog maybe prompto
will get another level up because he's
so inexperienced in normal activities
like eating eggs and
running whiz chocoo post what's a o
chocobos is I mean if there's chocoo
music there I'm there so let's go what
what are the exclamation points on the
map are they little mini events uh
they're Quest markers for like main
storyline quests oh all right so are
there six main storyline quests in this
demo no those are all for the Behemoth
check it out oh they're different okay
cool see look they're like so that's one
of them they're all like markers like
that's the behemoths like okay Pursuit
path kills Okay cool so it's different
different things you can like track the
behem okay I have an idea let's go see
the chocobos and let's go to that
station up there I want to know what
that is what's this what is it it's a
item what is it do someone just leave a
tiny feather how cute and useless maybe
we can have it for dinner with our eggs
in a basket oh my God an E and A B an E
and A
B oh is this some inter species com that
oh my god dude you are just fighting
everything oh God no why you just run
did I just did I just you jumped off a
tree you just like Neo off a tree can I
do it again I don't know jump off a tree
jump off a tree your friends are dying
you're just like jumping off trees all
right gladiola killed a saber Tusk why
are you chasing the one that's running
oh it's almost dead yeah chase down end
its life put it out of its
misery I mean I wasn't I wanted to get
the like awful things like these little
things right here yeah those things are
ugly and
nasty oh look at him shooting he looked
actually real badass when he was
shooting like that oh someone just hip
checked me like out of the way all right
I which one's the the little blond dude
is uh prompto yeah okay so I have a
question for you if they do let you play
every character and you could play as
prompto would you prefer it that you
actually have to aim his gun or that
it's just like a sword that you can use
from
afar I don't know I doubt they'll let
you aim but that'd be kind of
ridiculous all right kill these monsters
and by that I mean these innocent beings
of the for they also attacked us they're
not totally innocent that's true that's
true but I also kind of feel like you're
fabricating lies against these poor
innocent animals that you stumbled into
just shooting around the battlefield and
like yeah just warp
striking that was satisfying I'll give
you that he's like oh did you see that
he was like yes was he yeah I missed
that it mocking not this man I am a
prince oh oh that was cool some of the
movements are nice in this all right
let's go let's go hey bros walking with
my Bros walking with my Bros bro look at
them come on
kids kids P that tree out of the way all
right let's go find a thing are you in
another battle everywhere oh my God it
is a it is a real jungle out
here you were going to make all of these
extinct you were going to murder every
one of these in the world I know but
this is really like like so you have the
option to run away yeah give the option
to use diplomacy and peace but you know
I mean why when you can murder all right
oh my God come here mother oh you son of
a [__] shoot him not
you you got him all right let's get out
of this Forest before any more saber
test come out of the
woodwork oh man I so
tired do you guys see what I see no no
what I'm so tired I'm going to hide in a
bush wait what is that over there hold
R1 yeah what is
that what so just like another tiny
feather didn't need to see that I
believe that is what they call a clue oh
it's like the Behemoth Trail so we're
near we're near the Behemoth I just want
to see some jobos
guys that was my poor attempt at The
chob Bu music
I feel like if you go up there you're
going to get Behemoth yeah I'm not going
to go up there all right let's go find
this Chocobo post can you I wonder if
you can ride a chocobo in this demo is
that a thing I don't know I really hope
so he got tired is that why you're not
sprinting he keeps getting tired yeah so
I'm sprinting right now Sprint Sprint
Sprint Sprint Sprint Sprint Sprint
sprinting sprinting sprinting sprinting
sprinting sprinting sprinting look at
the are you narrating his sprinting yeah
so I've been sprinting this entire time
he's he's not stupped
maybe you're oh there you go and I'm
still holding down the Sprint I am sorry
I doubted you I feel like a real jerk
come on man come on man go at that weird
Arch they could never what is that is
that a
tent oh they're
domes go steal some eggs in a basket
from these fools hey guys you got any
ease and a be give me all your ease and
a bee it's more of an intuition all
right hang a left at those egg
domes oh it's a car oh what is this
little joint joint it looks like an
outdoor eating establishment why don't
you just steal their car and get on with
the main story yeah seriously can we
take this car uh Prince here
commandeering this vehicle I'm a prince
Grand Theft Final Fantasy can we take it
why can't we take that car Grand Theft
screw off I'm a prince is more like it I
am the prince oh this is the Cho how you
ch ch ch Cho ch
ch ch ch here is the Final Fantasy 15
chocoo I just want to hop up on that
saddle how happy they are listen they E
music it's so pleasant this is this is
bringing me warm tingly feelings all
over my body oh
there's hi he's looking at you hi joob
he's like take me
home oh my God oh my can you are can you
talk to any of the NPCs here like who's
that lady come
Andy to me hey babe baby on the she
looked at me did you see yeah she was
like look at this hey baby I'm the
Prince she's like that guy spent more
time on his hair this morning than I did
oh oh you just knocked her over she's
like you rude look at her she looks like
Rea doesn't she oh yeah she may she's
not not happy with me at all probably
now this is what she did after Final
Fantasy 8 she was like I'm just going to
work at the post post there was a piece
paper on the
table rampant Goblin
Crim you know that is the worst when
there is just a rampant Goblin CRI I
hate when the Goblins are like super
rampant with see if you can buy a
chocobo or gasel greens blah blah blah G
greens talk to this fatty and see what's
up hey rude he's he's okay he's cly he's
he has a fat face come around looking
for a chocobo ride no I no I just came
to the chocoo post for my health they're
not ready oh he's telling me the CH
aren't ready why does he have dream
catchers here all right let's buy some
food so we have a bunch of eggs like we
have some already and we have a gigy ham
just buy the most expensive one a ponus
tenders aaro I have do two sirines Aster
potions get a get some of that no you
already have as want some as rooms it's
a puns with Sirin let's get two let's
have some steak mushrooms let's get four
why not this game is making me hungry uh
let's get some tenders I think Square
Enix is in collusion with uh with food
distributors and they're going to start
selling all of these egg in a basket
will come with every copy of 15 an E and
A B get a quick E and A B before you
start your
adventure oh look another poster of the
Behemoth that that thing must really be
terrorizing she looks just likea doesn't
she look at this NPC look at her face
she's locking on you with her eyeballs
hi I can't talk to you right now that's
okay it's more just like a silent sultry
romance where they stare at one another
but never actually contact I think we
can o feed the birds again dear I love
watching their little beaks PE
at this is the worst date they are on
the worst date right now look at the
look at the way they're looking at each
other oh they have a a tattered
relationship that is they're trying to
mend with Chocobo tourist tourism can I
talk to you no no that man is just Why
can't I steal this car I don't know it
seems absurd to me tiny feather they
really shouldn't just build morality
into the mechanics of neon car though
it's so Co a hot pickup so this is the
chocoo ranch do we want to go to the
other side of the map to this garage to
the garage I don't know maybe we should
uh and we can walk all the way there no
that sounds terrible maybe we could
that's
1,200 want I want to see how long it
takes us all right let's do it people of
of the stream I oh my god oh that was a
stupid move that was a bad move just
jump and
knce go for a nice stroll yeah yeah I
guess we could just walk 12 and a half
hundred meters just you know any old day
look at those arches let's see what we
find along the way I know there's a
bunch of other different animals can you
see there's a highway right there you
could literally just Grand Theft Auto
this stand in the middle of the road and
take one of their
cars I think it was either your footage
or Peter's footage from PX I was
watching you guys play this after the
fact and I think it was Peter actually
stands in the highway and tries to take
one of the cars yeah he like stands and
waits until they stop and then just
tries to like Grand Theft Auto it it's
like it's so ingrained in like the the
mind of people who play games that you
can just take at whatever car all right
these are bad dudes so I would like to
kill them they are Bad Dudes
show to talk draon
jump you hang up in the air so long in
that move that's what draon jumps are I
know it's just hilarious in uh in
previous Final Fantasy games it was you
be in the air for an entire turn isn't
that doesn't Freya do that in N
yeah saber tus
claw that's one saber tus I love that I
love that warp move so much me too it's
really cool it's super
satisfying
oh
stasis you better chill on the warps man
you're going stasis
crazy oh just get behind this rock it's
found
me someone shoot this thing why is no
one fighting they are look at them is
just screwing around over
there I'm going to watch them and see if
they kill anything come on glad live up
to your name oh it's com for me all
right end this all right end this
now oh another magitech troop
transport's Coming For
You Handel it you're about to get
magitech I don't want to get mag I know
but it's not up to you I mean you better
you could run yeah I don't want run more
robots to fight so far I have to say I
wish I know this is a demo of one area
of the game early in the game but I wish
the enemy variety was a little ramped up
I'm betting it'll be different for sure
I'm sure it will but I'm saying like in
this one area wouldn't it be nice to see
like a I mean I'd say there's like five
enemy types we've seen if if that big
thing is
fightable dry age tend roast good thing
we bought those as rooms good thing we
bought those mushrooms from a strange
man from a strange man at the strange
man in the woods wow it's going to be a
weird night Alexa oh my God these God
these food is this is just making me
really hungry look at that look at that
look at the marbling on that tender
roast oh I really want like Ramen Prime
sharp we are now Prime sharp and immune
I'm feeling prime prime as hell is that
a City Light little display back there
looks like
it all right let's see how much this
gets
us why is noctis like at a baby level I
don't know because he's the little baby
Prince like he has do have the
experience that these Street urgin do
greatly increases attack defense
increases critical hit rate negates
status ailments okay cool now I wonder
how we get that summon I wonder if it's
a level up thing or if there's a world
event somewhere in here yeah let's go
find it maybe there's a material ball
kicking around in the woods you just got
to step on material ball yeah you know
seven
style mhm mhm I wonder let's check the
map do I have to like cross see if
there's any
hints to the station don't you go near
that sa I'm not going to touch him but
the station is a quest destination so
why don't we pop there before we go see
the pop in popping in pop in and then
pop off yeah let's go check that out and
then let's go kill this
Behemoth before my anticipation
overtakes me if the station is where I
think it is I think we might get to say
hi to a certain mechanic oh Lord I have
qualms with that character design yeah
yeah I have just for anyone who has not
seen the character of Sydney uh pretty
much every Final Fantasy has a character
named Sid who's like usually like the
mechanic the tech guy the guy fixing the
Airship all that kind of stuff so for
the first time Sid and 15 is female but
they really could have taken a better
Direction because she's like a innuendo
slinging sex goddess like it's she's got
like her breasts out yeah she's got her
breasts out and it's like is that
necessary was that practical for a
mechanic she's an attractive lady I'm
not trying to hate on her she's a good-
looking gal but a little sexist to just
make one s and her and her yeah I mean
her outfit is a little she's wearing
like like jean shorts what she's got
Jorts what look at what look at I don't
know oh my God no please go away go away
go away go away there's a thing over
there I know he said come look and now I
can't find it well screw it that's
probably what is yeah what was
that like I'm playing rust right now
walking around the woods picking oh it's
more like Behemoth better know
Behemoth oh [__] Are we near it I don't
want to be near it it is upon us oh
God I hope it can't smell my
fear you're such a little whiny [__]
promto I got an as room prompto is like
he reminds me of a character from
Miyazaki film I just can't remember
which
one he's just like such an anime
character I'm not interested in fighting
you dude smells like choco smells like
choco find a wild chocoo does that mean
there's one nearby if it said that I
think so my God wait did can you catch a
chocobo in this um I don't think you can
catch chocoo in the demo oh I want to I
did find the Chocobo when I played it uh
during packs what happened uh we hung
out well did that Quest did you have
that Quest yeah did it accomplish yeah
oh so the quest is just to literally see
one yeah to just find chocoo then hang
out with chocoo hang out with the chocoo
300 experience points can you fight
those giant Behemoth monsters not
literal behemoths but you know what I'm
talking about dinosaurs I I don't think
so you want to find out also I'm having
a a I don't like his melee bege thing
it's a little heavy for me spander so
I'm change German for two-hander I'm
going to put put the bloodsword there
bloodsword put it in the books well that
ends maybe he'll move a little faster
yeah maybe uh do you want to try and
fight that giant dinosaur yeah let's see
if I can get to I think the people want
to know if you can fight giant dinosaurs
is that a
feature I think that thing is going to
it's going to ruin your
life oh there's a thing over there well
too late
now oh hello massive I can't go in the
water oh wait go walk left and try to
get close to its head N I don't think
it's going to let you go near I just
want to say hello hi oh
hi that's as close as I can get it what
is this a zoo why can't you get any
closer wait look at it it's looking at
you look at you looking at me looking at
you no it's not hey buddy just do thing
all right let's get out of here you
can't touch it than if I can't touch
that dinosaur I want to touch a dinosaur
but if I can't touch a dinosaur I'm not
going to hang out in your a dinosaur I
want to touch it well it's too bad I
know I'm sad it's not a feature in desk
I bet though I bet I bet you can be
you'll be able to fight those things
like the like the longu in 13 yeah the
long there it
is it's it's a black
Chocobo we found it judge him not by the
color of his feathers Alexa but by the
content of
his there's a tooo look at it oh bye
come back come back no I don't think you
can do anything with it you just have to
find it why don't you warp strike it and
then I can't I can't Target it I know
I'm just kidding that'd be so cruel it's
like get away all right I'll leave you
to you does it have to be a black chobo
cuz they're dressed all in black like is
this is there just like a a m goth theme
going here I think so a Hot Topic
Chocobo all right something's the battle
system not cutting away to like another
screen is only confus I really like it
but it's confusing when it's it's just
like there's a thing near you it just
doesn't tell you
what all you going up to karck station
here yeah cool I think I'm going to
going to take this path up maybe you can
carjack someone up there maybe we can
carjack someone maybe you can trade
someone an egg in a basket for a
car yeah he's moves much faster now that
he doesn't have that giant sword thank
God I don't think he's a small man he's
not meant for a giant
sword that's more of glados's territory
okay much better he just he just did a
Tiger Woods fist pump I swear to God
Tiger Wood no I saw it I saw it the
Tiger Woods fist pump is thing it's so
subtle it was so subtle oh my God
running just a little
celebration running up that easy as they
come no one second of battle no
experience gained all right I think yeah
there you go you're you're on a straight
path making my way downtown walking fast
oh knock this so now also he needs a
haircut cuz he's got this little baby
going on whoa don't look at my butt
prompto prompto is all up in your butt
don't look at my butt Bros bros Bros
bros Bros look at them they're all like
they're all look at they're like this
little clo together look at them look at
them all crouching too to
you go go go go also uh I love this
music yeah yokoshima mura uh who scores
the Kingdom Hearts series oh did this
done many other things yeah I have to
say I like the non nou umu music always
is like a a sore spot for me but this
music in this game is great so far love
that though I really like the trailer
music too like I had to use that when we
oh by the way uh people who like this
game are interested in it Alexa and I
did a feature it's a what Final Fantasy
15 can learn from the classics and it
went up this morning uh check it out
it's cool and it's like me Alexa spent a
long time you spent a long time Shake It
Off did you see that just shook it off
but yeah check it out it's what Final
Fantasy 15 can learn from the classics
and we spent too long on it for you to
not watch it yeah so please watch it
please watch it Maj justify our
existence no I'm just
kidding all right what's going on here
all right look at this Americana ass
Highway can you even get over there are
you what let grab something oh oh okay I
was blocked I was like why the hell does
he get to go warped
through all work no play oh this is
where Sydney is first let's see if we
can score some spicy food yeah score
some spicy food
that's really the priority
here oh no I'm going to wait there's hot
Carson me another step why are they all
dressed like Nathan Drake I I have no
idea maybe they're on an adventure too
to be now maybe that's another bro crew
dude okay can you wait walk over them oh
for [__] sake wait before you go see
Sydney before you go see Sydney walk
over to those guys for one second with
your crew those the dud Bros over there
hold on lady just give her a second can
we just do okay now Pan the camera
around so I can see your your homies
after this I can't okay well here we go
let's just do a little side by side here
these men are they all all wearing
scarves which is a little off but they
dressed so normally do you know how they
would feel about your crew if you
strolled up looking like that do you
know how all our Jack they like are you
guys like cosplaying or like what is
going on here are you are you the
protagonist of a Final Fantasy game all
right this I I have so much problems
with what's happening right now all
right let's uh let's roll out the red
carpet here for Sydney hey there good to
see you oh hey there
I think it's cute that she's like
Southern I like the accent she's just
not wearing any clothes how about y
except for leg warmers that go up to her
butt look at that car yeah it's a hot
car is that a bottle opener on her
jacket I don't know business somehow I
think it's a strap for her pocket we
broke it we bought
it she's a fine one this girl oh my God
she won't take nothing less than the
best part
is was that in uendo or am I reading too
much into this and that's to do it right
all things you're getting a steel yeah
think we don't know it when we finally
pay our bill off we'll throw in at
dinner too best save that for paa when I
told him y'all broke down again he was
redder than
Rama see it's
Rama all right well oh my God look at
this car hold on I just got it with the
car it's like a final see Bentley look
at this
car that's a hot car actually I would
drive that car if hey uh Square Enix if
you guys start making these cars yeah
seriously someone gam spot we'll uh
we'll drive that around we'll review the
car well 10 out of 10 this car's hot 10
10 awesome hot
car game's good car is better all right
wasn't that trailer oh now you can rent
the trailer and sleep in it we don't
want to do that we've rested
enough yeah no man you don't have enough
money ate you spent all your money SP my
money on food fat all right so let's get
out of this Nathan Drake ass gas station
Nathan Drake ass gas station do we want
to go after the Behemoth let's do it let
time it's time there's there's nothing
that I want to do more than kill that
Behemoth say see its blood splatter upon
noctis' leather
jacket sorry that was graphic that was
oddly specific you know I'd like to get
oddly specific check out this
road cool all right let's go for that
Behemoth let's end this now is this a is
there a car coming oh my God this car
coming
hey oh it's oh let me take your car
excuse me Sarah Sarah stop stop in the
name of the prince in the name of the
prince he swered around me oh look oh
gladiola stopped him good job gladiolas
oh let him go all right let's go kill
okay I wanted the car so bad we're going
in the right direction oh you got I
think it's a yeah it's a hard
left we came we came up this end so
we'll go down the other side why don't
you just leap over and walk stra there
look at this though this is cool did you
never take geometry just cut this the
hypotenuse this
[__] take the hypotenuse oh fine just
jump fine fine fine yeah
geometry you're just going to LEAP all
the way there just going
toasy all right hey I I have a fear that
we will run out of stream time if we do
not go
so peace oh my God unlock you go all
right go yeah go go go around this way
there you go oh my god did you see the
blood splatters ran by you should let
your goons take care of that you are a
prince after all you you don't need to
get your hands dirty I am a prin that's
what you have gladiolas for he's your
muscle gladio gladio gladio glad let's
walk by the dinosaur is good yeah
they're cool I really want to fight them
though me too I'm betting I'm betting in
the fin
for sure maybe I mean I feel like even
if they let you fight him in this it
would just be a matter of you getting
kicked in the face dying immediately and
it would be no fun oh my God I mean
Final Fantasy kicked in the fa episode
kicked in the face episode kicked in the
mouth he's all swey oh come on I kind of
where are they where's the other one I
don't know let him he'll catch up hey oh
the the Derpy blonde kid look at him
he's like guys I thought you left me
he's like he's like a a kid who can't
find his mom at the mall he's like
somebody help all right my god let's go
tired ass noctus come on kids oh my God
they're so funny I love that prompto was
all the way back there I'm just like hey
guys oh I think I have to run around
this yeah I have to run around it I'm
going to get my hair done exactly like
noctis I am getting a haircut today
maybe I'll get like a final F BR a
picture of noctis hi can you cut my hair
like this can you make me look just like
this make me look like a Final Fantasy
character uh full disclosure for the
past uh maybe 10 years of my life I have
brought pictures of Final Fantasy
characters into my hairdressers being
like can you just do this cuz I don't
have a frame I don't have like a good
frame of reference to be like well I
kind of want you to do this and I want
you to do that full disclosure I cut my
hair with scissors in the mirror because
I don't really
care okay 500 M getting
close just all this battle music is
making it feel so
dramatic do you get extra experience for
parrying is that why it always counts
your pares oh that's cool the Parry
system is kind of cool I like that I'm
never good at defending because I just
want to hit things until they die yeah
fair enough this is an Assassin's Creed
you don't want to just like wait with
your wrist blade out yeah I've had
enough of that
Ubisoft all right we're getting close I
want to see this battle I've been this
has been yeah screw that but it's
probably a tiny feather or an egg in a
basket it's an E and A B it's another E
and A B gladi I really want an E and A B
yeah let's go out for e and B's after
you want to go out for an E and A B
we're done probably I mean I'm not
making any commitments cuz I'm not that
hungry
but I'm looking at all that stew has
made me very hungry and I like brought
lunch today but all I want is like some
freaking like like uh bealou yeah bealou
bealou stew okay if you're taking me out
for bealou stew after this I'm in bealou
a nice St Patrick's Day traditional
beope the old Trad ask Danny O DWI it's
an old tradition to eat bealou every
March 17th Tre light no all right 150 M
get
close just Sprint yo no just run through
him did you see me hit cheuck him out of
the way excuse me excuse me I got a big
human excuse me pardon me I got bigger
fishy sorry we're running through all
the enemies but we super want to like
yeah no I'm sure the stream has seen
enough of us murdering small animals
it's time to murder large animals yeah
my oh noctis you are just you have no
endurance yeah he poops out really
easily cuz he's been sitting on his
hunches in the Kingdom for 20 odd years
getting
fat oh my God something off here we go
oh boy oh
Christ go kill
it uh there's nothing there yeah what
happened I don't know those trees
spontaneously fell down looky well
there's just a lumberjack hanging out
he's like oh what's up guys they're just
chopping down trees I don't know I
didn't mean to scare you oh you know
just Final Fantasy Lumberjack yeah why
wasn't s a
lumberjack you guys are chasing Paul
bunion Through the
Woods dead eyes denn is Frau with
danger all right going straight into his
danger fra
Den there are no campgrounds around here
you don't need to Camp go murder it told
me to make it told me to make Camp oh
well since when did you ever listen to
the
tutorial oh oh I can't that looked like
a tunnel I know sure looked like a
tunnel out of my way guys come on come
guys move guys guys guys guys guys
they're all just like crowding up behind
you tiny feather told you dude it's just
tiny feathers out here oo spy o maybe
I'll make a sword out of tiny feathers
oh my God please go away I do not have
time for you
guys you might have to make
time
sweet oh he moved okay that sucks yep it
doesn't Auto Target no but that's kind
of cool actually that like they can
dodge by just like targeting someone
else cuz I bet that goes both ways yeah
like I bet if someone draon jumped you
you could just move run out of the way
yeah exactly do that I kind of dig that
better than just standing there waiting
to take it yeah boom stasis oh god oh so
tired oh let me guys I'll be napping
I'll be sleeping behind this rock
nocus has lives such a cushy life he
can't even finish his own battles oh
diamond oh god look look he's protecting
me a with his Diamond gloves he's
standing in front of me all right
Michael Jackson please leave me alone
I'm trying to like you're good warp
strike out of here go kill those
things knew you wer completely
useless I love that like oh my god oh
yeah I have no MP you good you good so
attacking this is interesting cuz
attacking
uh drains MP but I think that's cuz
you're doing the warp strike does it if
you're just doing normal no it doesn't I
it just it just oh maybe cuz his his
weapons are magic too so maybe that's
why cuz he doesn't actually carry like a
big sword he like conjures it on the fly
all right let's go chase down this beamo
he needs wait do I literally have to go
no don't your MP will come
back you don't need bed rest to get your
magic points back yeah but look how fast
faster it goes when I in a this is true
dudes in a bush Final Fantasy dudes in a
bush
fantas yeah they're like hey you done
your highness do you need to szip your
fly for you oh my God your highness all
right like your loness yeah okay go
towards the are we going that way or
this way uh uh it looks like that way
but maybe uh yeah there you go just
maybe go to that icon no just keep going
just keep going screw it
it's I don't know what it's telling you
to go to oh it's an item it's item
that's just an item did I come up this
way though I don't really know I'm kind
of lost here it's a little
Misty place is littered with tiny
feathers oh my God dragon scales and I'm
in a dead end aren't I okay cool yeah so
go back the other way we were
considering no Final Fantasy the
Labyrinth within my God are the spirits
within uh so I'm reading a book right
now called Final Fantasy and philosophy
oh God that someone wrote where they
like is good uh yeah kind of and they
write about they write about about the
spirits within and it's really funny I
saw that movie in theaters like when it
came out oh my God I keep running into
dead ends why I don't know look at your
map hang in their stream we're going to
fight this giant
Beast going to hug I think wait look at
your map I think this is going to lead
to that dead end again no you're right
keep going keep
going we need like a cartographer to do
this all right hang a left I think yeah
see if you can get out this
way that's a good sign items
cro really dark yeah all right there you
go move it doter get your butt out of
the
way they won't let me go first he's like
you're a prince you're too valuable my
life is worthless and I have nothing to
live for so according to the story this
guy gladiolus has been raised from birth
to protect
noctis that's pretty badass so he's like
his bodyguard right yeah so I'm actually
controlling noctis right now oh awesome
like this is me I am controlling him
cool it's getting very dark um but he's
been raised from birth to protect him
ignis the guy that cooks has been raised
from birth to advise him and prompto is
just some random dude urg right yeah who
like became noctis's friend okay this
part's
cool hold up don't talk so loud dude
it's right
there see he's
blinding oh that's why they call him
dead eye that makes sense
yep there you go gladiolus almost had
the same thing it looks like he had a
scar right through his eye he probably
relates to him he's likees this Noble
Beast is much like
I yeah let's do
it okay all right so we got to wrap this
up very very soon all right let's try
and kill this thing I know you don't I
know you don't kill it right now this
sequence is actually pretty long there's
a stealth sequence kill him all right
well let's do we get to fight it at all
right now or no no damn I think we might
have to let it go cuz we got the lobby
coming up very soon okay all right so
well we did our best we did do our best
I oh God oh God this is a horribly tense
moment
done I actually think this is a good
time to I think this is a good time too
because you know what we won't spoil the
battle with Behemoth yeah we don't want
to spoil the Behemoth Folks At Home
Folks at home you can fight the Behemoth
on your own the behemoth theem you can f
the Behemoth on your own um thanks for
watching this is out today if you have
Final Fantasy type zero the code should
come with it um the lobby is coming up
at two we'll be talking more Final
Fantasy and other great stuff yes you
will you'll be talking about Final
Fantasy on the lobby I'll be talking
about Final Fantasy on the lobby so if
you want to hear more then see you at
two thanks for watching guys goodbye I
love you
all
he